and i think one thing with climate we
talk about our climate impact as it's as
an isolated issue but we need to talk
about it as an aspect of fossil fuel use
so it's a side effect of fossil fuel use
so i do believe there is the side effect
we have to look at it in the context of
the benefits and so part of my argument
is going to be that the benefits of
fossil fuels far far outweigh any
negative side effects yeah so climate
change is is definitely occurring and in
fact i think there's very little
argument over that at this point um even
the the most ardent opponents
acknowledge the climate is changing i
mean all you have to do is look out your
window caused by
uh human activities mainly the emission
of carbon dioxide and you know the
evidence is so strong that
if you were on a jury you would have no
qualms about convicting carbon dioxide
of of changing the climate
welcome to episode 126 of the michaela
peterson podcast opposing views has the
format where i speak with one person
with one view of a contentious subject
and another person with the opposite
view i find it insanely interesting
in this episode we covered climate
change with andrew destler and alex
epstein
the controversy around climate change
spans more than a century the crucial
point being whether climate change is
happening and if so how much humans
contributed to that especially after the
industrial revolution
my first guest andrew destler is a
professor of atmospheric sciences at
texas
a m
and a climate scientist who studies the
science and politics of climate change
destler served as a senior policy
analyst for the clinton administration
and is the author of two books
introduction to modern climate change
and the science and politics of global
climate change a guide to the debate
then on the second half i had alex
epstein on alex is a philosopher author
energy theorist and industrial policy
pundit
he founded the center for industrial
progress
and wrote
the moral case for fossil fuels a new
york times bestseller arguing that
contrary to popular belief humanity
needs fossil fuels to flourish
if you enjoy this episode please
consider subscribing and let me know
what you think about climate change or
which arguments you found the most
compelling in the comments below
this episode is brought to you by rabbit
air i had serious trouble getting
quality deep sleep especially when i was
stressed out i had no idea why other
than the stress couldn't figure it out
turns out i was having allergies to the
dust in my room because i'm allergic to
everything it was a new condo so i was
surprised i got an air purifier and it
increased my deep sleep by 30 right away
i used my aura ring to test that
rabbit air has a super clean very
attractive air purifier that i recommend
to everyone now it's quiet it's easy to
clean and it looks great in rooms it's
changed the way i sleep
their bio gs 2.0 model
i'll show you guys look at that baby
won the world's most prestigious red dot
design award thanks to its stylish
design and the advanced filtration
technology that targets airborne
allergens particles and odors
effectively
cute huh even if you have no issues
sleeping we still breathe in nearly 2
000 gallons of air a day and decades of
research have shown that air pollutants
raise both the number
of cases and severity of lung and heart
disease among other health problems
stuffy nose for example on top of that
according to the epa americans spend
around 90 of their time indoors which is
horrifying where the air is two to five
times more polluted than outside
thankfully rabbit air's purifiers have a
six-stage filtration system that traps
even micron size pollutants
which can range from mildly annoying to
seriously harmful depending on where you
live and the air quality around you and
if you're not convinced rabid air offers
a five-year warranty free shipping and
returns and a 90-day money-back
guarantee on all their products
do yourself a favor visit rabbitair.com
today to see their models or call them
24 7 to speak to a rabbit air consultant
that's rabbit like the bunny
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r-rabbitaire.com
for some of the best air purifiers
you'll find anywhere
and ones that look good
alex epstein welcome to my podcast hey
great to be here
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
uh sure i think myself as two things a
philosopher and energy expert those two
don't always go together but so
philosopher is somebody who helps people
think more clearly about important
issues in life
and then i study energy you know which
is the food that our machines use to
make our lives uh better and
i think maybe that the biggest
difference between me and other people
is of a very explicitly pro-human uh
philosophy for thinking about energy and
also the way it impacts the rest of
nature and i my view this might be
controversial i think that most people
actually have an anti-human way of
thinking about energy and our
environment and i believe the ma the
main differences on this issue are not
scientific they're philosophical
interesting okay that's a fun way of
looking at it well
we're going to be talking about
climate change
fossil fuels renewable energy
i interviewed somebody who was kind of
on the other side of the debate i guess
which would be
more you know fossil fuels are
not
what we should be using anymore i guess
that would be summed up as his argument
but i'm going to ask you guys similar
questions so people can see the
differences in answers so first of all
what are your views on just an overview
on
climate change and how much of that is
a problem because of humans
yeah
so i think the the key way of thinking
so just to
look at it from a philosophical
perspective i think there are a few ways
of looking at it that
help clarify things and also help
explain why a lot of the catastrophe
thinking doesn't make much sense so the
first thing is we just have to be
precise about what we mean so i prefer
to talk about like man-made climate
impact versus climate change because
climate change is very ambiguous like
what kind of change how big and then
also who is causing it so i do believe
in man-made climate impact so that's one
thing i'll say that and then but when
you're looking at man-made climate
impact you have to look at it in its
full context and in particular you need
to look at it as a side effect of fossil
fuel use
so you know we're talking a lot these
days about antibiotics about vaccines
particularly vaccines and whatever
anyone thinks of a particular vaccine i
think everyone would agree you have to
look carefully at both the benefits of a
vaccine and the side effects of a
vaccine and you have to weigh them and i
think one thing with climate we talk
about our climate impact as it's as an
isolated issue but we need to talk about
it as an aspect of fossil fuel use so
it's a side effect of fossil fuels so i
do believe there is the side effect we
have to look at it in the context of the
benefits and so part of my argument is
going to be that the benefits of fossil
fuels far far outweigh any negative side
effects from climate and in particular
this is true because fossil fuels like
with the vaccine or antibiotic they have
benefits and side effects that are
somewhat unrelated like okay they'll
cure you of a condition if it's
antibiotic but then it has a side effect
but fossil fuels are actually magical
because their benefits actually cure
their side effects so let's say fossil
fuels leads to an increase in drought
well but fossil fuels also allow you to
purify water they also allow you to
irrigate water they also allow you to
move food from where you have a good
harvest to where you have a bad harvest
and what we see over the past 100 years
and i believe we have
we have impacted water somewhat in the
world it's hard to say positive or
negative i think but whatever has
happened drought-related deaths have
gone down by over 99
over the last century people think of
them as getting worse but they're
actually getting better why is that in
large part because the benefit of fossil
fuels one key benefit is drought mastery
so we've increasingly become
masters
of drought and so it's just one way in
which if you don't look at the benefits
of fossil fuels along with the climate
side effects you cannot think about it
rationally both because there are
benefits of fossil fuels to every area
of life like hospitals and food and so
on but there are many climate mastery
benefits uh in particular so that's
that's the second thing so we need to
look at it precisely we need to look at
it in the context the benefits including
the climate mastery benefits and then
the third thing is when we're looking at
man-made climate impact we cannot have
the bias that it's intrinsically wrong
usually when people talk about climate
change there's this assumption that it's
immoral and it must be bad
and my view is you need to actually look
at it and if you're talking about
something like rising co2 levels leading
to a warming impact on the global
climate system you can be pretty sure
that there's going to be at least a lot
of positive from that it could easily be
outweighed by the negative but there's a
lot of positive in the world getting
warmer particularly if you study the
models and the history
it tends to get warmer in some of the
coldest places in the world particularly
at northern latitudes that's why there's
so much focus on the arctic melting but
that's from a human perspective probably
a good thing because what it means is
places like siberia get warmer than
places like mexico and if you look at
the history of the planet i think this
this holds true when the really warm
periods like the world has been 25
degrees fahrenheit warmer than it is
today
but it's not that the equator got super
warm it's that the poles
get warmer the other thing about co2
that's related to climate is it related
to life is that it's a fertile it has a
fertilizing effect and so the reason i'm
bringing up both the benefits of warming
and fertilizing is not to say that they
outweigh the negatives on their own but
that we have an anti-human impact bias
we tend to think of rising co2 because
we created it oh it must be bad and so i
think these three failures to think
about the issue precisely to look at the
benefits and to look at the impacts from
a pro-human unbiased perspective i think
that's actually what causes people think
that climate change is the end of the
world i think if you look at it in the
full context from a human perspective i
think it's fairly obvious that we should
be using far more fossil fuels
okay that was good uh
where do i want to start with that okay
what about the argument that we should
be transitioning from fossil fuels to
renewable sources of energy
how do you feel about that
yeah so i think that argument itself uh
betrays a couple of things so one is the
the obsession with renewable i think
should be a red flag to anyone it's a
question of like why are we obsessed
with renewable because in practice
renewable means primarily solar and wind
if you look at renewable mandates most
of them exclude large-scale hydro and
they certainly exclude nuclear and what
large-scale hydro and nuclear have in
common is they are by far the two most
practical proven non-carbon alternatives
to fossil fuels now they can't do
everything fossil fuels can do and solar
wind certainly can't
so they don't produce they're not really
good at really high temperatures for
industry and they're certainly not good
for heavy-duty transportation although
nuclear could be in the future but
they're pretty good at generating a lot
of electricity uh particularly nuclear
because you can use it anywhere in the
world and yet the modern anti-fossil
fuel movement that says rising co2
levels are an existential threat
they deliberately exclude nuclear and
hydro so why is that why do they insist
on renewable and my view is that's a
philosophical thing renewable is viewed
as natural like we're not impacting
nature as much and so that's why they
favor it and then in practice what you
see though is actually there's a lot of
opposition to solar and wind and
practice like the amount of mining we're
doing the amount of building of these
things and the amount of transmission
line building is not at all keeping pace
with what people say is necessary
but it's getting opposed by what by
green activists saying hey this has too
much impact so what you can see with the
opposition not just to fossil fuels but
nuclear hydro and renewables is that
there's this idea that human impact is
bad and we have to stop it and that's a
philosophical view and that's the view
that our ultimate goal or our main goal
should be to eliminate human impact on
nature and my goal is or i think our
goal should be to advance human
flourishing and that's why i think
that's there's a so that's the first
flag like to advocate renewable is is
suspicious and then to advocate
renewable and to not be concerned by the
fact that renewables being stopped all
over the world that's another flag is if
you notice most people don't know that
the renewable development is being
stopped by the green movement
all around the world it's really hard to
build this stuff and yet if you look at
the news media and the advocates of the
stuff and the politicians they almost
never talk about the fact that green is
green the green movement is stopping
them but they're so gung-ho about still
restricting fossil fuels even though
their alleged replacement isn't even
allowed uh to work and the other thing
is if you look at this stuff in practice
we're now living through this right now
in the world and particularly in europe
what's happened is we've made policies
for the past 20 years saying hey we can
restrict fossil fuels
and solar and we're going to mandate and
subsidize a lot of solar wind and
they'll make up the difference and
what's happening right now fossil fuel
prices are skyrocketing people are
scrambling for natural gas and coal what
does that mean that means the promise
that these could be easily replaced by
the solar and wind was a false promise
what's happening is when china needs
energy they're not trying to build more
windmills they're trying to get coal and
natural gas from around the world so
that's another indication and the basic
reason for why this stuff doesn't work
at all is that it's fundamentally an
unreliable input so the sun and the wind
are unreliable you can call them
intermittent but basically you need a
you need a controllable source of energy
to to get electricity and so when you
insist on having solar and wind
those can go down to near zero at any
point so it doesn't replace the reliable
power plants it just adds to the cost of
reliable power plants and then what
happens and what's happened in texas and
california where i live
is that the costs go way up and so what
they try to do is they try to cut down
on reliable power plants like here we've
shut down a big nuclear plant natural
gas plants and you play this game of
reliability chicken where you hope that
there's enough solar and wind and you
hope that it doesn't get too hot or too
cold but then last summer it gets too
hot in california the wind dies down we
have blackouts in texas it gets too cold
they have mass blackouts so these
technologies in reality are total
failures
and anyone advocating them needs to
acknowledge that and so the fact that
they advocate these total failures they
don't acknowledge it they don't care
about the fact they're being restricted
they oppose nuclear they oppose hydra
they oppose fossil fuels it really is
pretty straightforward that this is it's
all about the morality of eliminating
human impact and it's not at all about
actually being concerned about energy
the final fact is most of the world
doesn't have much energy so 1.5 billion
people only use one third or more of the
electricity that we use in the us over
three billion people use less
electricity per person than the average
american refrigerator
and then three billion people are
between us one third of us and a
refrigerator
so the world needs far more energy so
the fact that we're not talking about
radically expanding the availability of
energy
once again shows that we have an
anti-energy culture that's all about
eliminating human impact and is not
really focused on advancing human
flourishing
okay that was a lot of information i'm
going to address a couple of that was
great no no i'm going to address a
couple of things you said so
i've i've heard that the mass blackouts
in texas were caused by water freezing
in the natural gas pipes
is that true because then that would be
a natural gas problem not a not a
turbine problem
um yeah so i think i think when i tried
it by the when i'm trying to explain
stuff i try to when possible rely on
facts that everyone has access to and so
this i think we can also rely on facts
that everyone has access to to see what
is the problem so i think you're from
canada right or originally yeah canada
yeah take alberta canada is a place with
a lot of parallels to texas except it's
much much colder right but it's a place
where it has a fairly because people say
oh texas has an isolated grid and that's
the problem alberta has a fairly
isolated grid
um i did a post if people go to
energytalkingpoints.com and they just
search the word alberta you can see the
data here but basically if you look at
that exact period of time alberta was
colder throughout than texas was and yet
they had no problems with blackouts now
is it because they avoided the plague of
natural gas no they were using about
half natural gas in about half coal why
didn't they have a problem well because
natural gas and coal are totally capable
of dealing with winter temperatures if
they have proper resiliency built in so
we know that the failure of natural gas
in texas was not something that's
inherent in natural gas it was inherent
in the way natural gas was used so there
were definitely failures with natural
gas but the point is they're not
inherent in natural gas so what happened
is what happened is texas has spent huge
amounts of money uh subsidizing wind and
trying to use as much wind as possible
to meet targets and that money comes at
the expense of both reliable power
plants but also the resiliency measures
such as weatherizing so there were some
definite failures with natural gas but
that's because natural gas was defunded
in order to fund this unreliable solar
and wind if you look again at
energytalkingpoints.com i think if you
search alberta you'll see this what you
see is what happened in texas is before
the freeze they were using large amounts
of wind because they always use as much
as they can and then even before the
turbines froze what happened is the wind
died down because wind dies down when
it's cold most of the time and when it's
really hot it's one reason why it's very
bad source of energy in practice and
very expensive because you always need
it doesn't it doesn't appear when you
need it the most so what happened with
wind was a problem inherent with wind
whereas what happened with gas is not a
problem inherent in gas it's a problem
inherent with defunding gas to pay for
wind so any honest assessment of this by
anyone who knows should have been okay
let's make the reliable stuff more
resilient
not let's keep using the wind that was
totally unavailable
okay and did the winter i don't want to
get stuck on this but i'm going to poke
around anyway did the wind turbines
freeze because of lack of wind or
because they weren't built to freeze
because the wind turbines in alberta
don't freeze
right so you can you can weather us this
is an important point there are too many
people who seized on the idea of wind
turbines freezing so again the the they
stopped producing power before they
started freezing because just the wind
wasn't blowing but yeah they freeze
because you have to weatherize them and
then that costs money so when you're
weatherizing things you just have to
look at what it is this worth it or not
and i think it's clearly worth it when
you have something that you can actually
control that's available when you have
something that you can't control that's
not available then you spend a fortune
weatherizing that well then it's not
going to work no matter what the if it's
really cold it's not going to work even
if it's not frozen
okay got it next question
is natural gas subsidized by the
government because the last guy i had on
he said
he said that uh wind turbines and
renewable energy was actually cheap
natural gas was expensive but it was
subsidized by the government that's
probably a poor explanation of what he
said but
yeah no but it's so i won't rely on on
what you're saying about him but this is
a kind of common argument um so i just i
keep making reference to the site in
case people want to see data but
energytalkingpoints.com you can just
search any term including subsidies so
you'll see the us government including
the biden administration every energy
admit uh any every energy information
administration basically has the same
data if you mean by subsidies like
payments to like cash payments taken
from us and given to companies uh the
subsidies of solar and wind you know are
between like 20 and 200 times what the
others get so what is happening there
why are they claiming subsidies there
they use a bunch of different things to
mean subsidies and the most common one
these days is let's say oh well the
negative climate impacts are subsidies
and so if we really paid the full cost
of the negative impacts on climate
then
you know that would be so we could talk
about that but it's not it's not really
a subsidy they're just saying oh it's
this excess cost and i guess my quick
view on that as well
that's a really hard claim to make
because if you look at the main thing we
should be concerned about with climate
which is people dying climate-related
disaster deaths are down 98 over the
past 100 years
and uh so we're actually safer from
climate than ever uh the other thing is
when you start looking at these kinds of
externality things not only do people
have no real ability to quantify any
real negatives from fossil fuels and
climate but the positives from fossil
fuels are just so incredible so you just
say something like um the fact that we
could use coal and gas in the 1970s made
possible you know the computer
revolution and the internet of the 1980s
and so every life saved by the internet
was made possible by the fossil fuel
industry so should we pay them a big
subsidy because they had all of these
what's called unpriced positive
externalities so i don't get too much
into that technical stuff but what it
shows is there's a bias always looking
for negatives from fossil fuels and not
looking for um positives but and then
the final thing about the subsidies and
this is where it's criminal that people
don't admit it the real thing that's
worse than a subsidy is that almost
every grid in the u.s has a completely
ridiculous payment policy that's that's
rigged toward uh wind and solar which is
you get paid the same for reliable
electricity as unreliable electricity so
that's just comple you would never do
that in work right you'd never say oh
i've got a like i'll pay the podcast
producer who comes in one third of the
time and i don't know when and the
podcast producer comes exactly what i
need them like if they're charging the
same rate that's not the same rate or if
somebody says like here's a car and
it'll work one third of the time that's
not the same as a car that works when
you need it but the way our grids work
for various bad historical reasons is
that they pay the same for a unit of
wind whenever it feels like coming in or
doesn't as they do for a win a unit of
nuclear and this is by the way a big
reason why nuclear is declining even
though it's very practical is we have
these unfair payment policies that pay
the same for wind and then what happens
is uh wind well
yeah it's a kind of long technical thing
but
nuclear if you look at the cost over
time makes so much more sense than
unreliable wind and solar but because of
the irrational payment policies we're
shutting down nuclear plants at record
rates and in a world where people claim
to care about co2 so again it shows the
goal is not at all about about lowering
emissions for some good human purpose
it's really just about eliminating all
all our impact and not caring about lack
of energy
okay um back to say climate change and
the potential disasters that are ensuing
because of rising co2 levels so what is
it with the argument that there are
going to be more hurricanes and that
water level is going to rise and that's
going to wipe out a bunch of the
population
how what are your thoughts on that
so
i think a good a good principle for
thinking is we should only trust
predictions about the future from people
who acknowledge the reality of the
present
it's really important because almost
everyone is a complete either completely
ignorant or if you're talking about
specialists who talk about this stuff
they are in denial about the fact that
we are far safer from climate than ever
so if you look at storm-related deaths
flood-related deaths which is related
sea level rises you have to acknowledge
that all of those are at record lows and
that a fossil-fueled world is a big
reason why fossil fuels allow us to use
machines to improve our lives all the
different kinds of climate protection
either involve like machines themselves
like irrigation machines or the using of
machines to build up this amazing
infrastructure so the fact that nobody
talks about how we're safer than ever
from climate and fossil fuels are
responsible
means in my view they should not be
trusted to talk about the future and in
particular because if you deny fossil
fueled climate mastery you can't think
intelligently about the future and a
good person on this issue you may know
him as bjorn lomborg who wrote a book
called false alarm and he does a really
good job of showing how many of these
things that get publicized ignore what
he calls adaptation i would call it
mastery so our ability to deal with
things so they'll act like oh the sea
level is going to rise and we're going
to do nothing about it people are just
going to let it rise and they're going
to drown and stuff and so one aspect you
could say is yeah a lot of these sea
level rise projections there's no reason
to believe them as extreme as they are
but the main thing is whatever happens
within the realm of possibility human
beings if free will be very very
adaptive and once you factor that in
it's almost impossible to think of
something that would be a problem i've
thought about this a lot because i i
wrote this book moral case for fossil
fuels and then i've i recently finished
up its sequel called fossil future and i
really have been thinking about what
would worry me if it happened and i
could only think of three things that
would actually worry me so one was if
there was a like totally uncontrollable
rise in temperatures that just somehow
accelerated and that turns out to be
physically impossible for reasons we can
discuss another one with storms is not
they're talking about storms that are
five percent more powerful that worries
me not one bit it's if they were three
or four times more powerful where they
could just totally like demolish cities
but there's no like even the extreme
people aren't predicting that and then
the other thing would be super rapid sea
level rises like multiple feet per
decade but even if you look at pretty
extreme un projections you're talking
about three feet in a hundred years
um so
it's just i do believe we impact climate
so i want to make the case that you can
believe totally that we impact climate
that's a side effect of fossil fuel use
but you can believe that it's a totally
masterable and worth it side effect of
fossil fuels this idea of oh you're a
climate change believer denier that's a
false alternative that's like saying
you're an antibiotic side effect
believer or antibiotic side effect
denier no you can believe that the
positives outweigh the negatives and and
again i think it's actually i know this
sounds weird but i think it's actually
very obvious in the case of fossil fuels
once you look at it from the right from
a pro-human
philosophical framework i don't even
think it's a close call that we should
actually be super terrified of climate i
think there's no basis for that actually
what are your views on so i feel like
most of the climate change
proponents not proponents sorry people
who are advocating to put carbon taxes
in or something like that i feel like
most of that's coming from either europe
or north america
what's the place in the world that
actually contributes the most to co2
it depends how you do it because you
know i mean in the aggregate it would be
china right i mean they're they're doing
the most and
it's important though that they have
still lower per capita than we do in
china so they're not at the level of
using less than a refrigerator per
person but they're somewhere like i
think still less than a third on average
yes they're getting they're getting to
that territory so one thing they'll say
which is legitimate is hey we're we're
still using way less per person than you
are and that's a legitimate argument the
other legitimate argument is
we are using their coal so there's this
idea oh china uses coal oh bad china but
what is china doing they're largely
producing stuff for us
so when we buy something from china we
are using the coal most of the energy we
use is not energy we consume directly
with the machines in our house it's
mostly energy used to produce the
products and services and that energy
that we use and that energy exists
around the world so it is
the most notable thing about china i
think is they are the most obvious
refutation of the idea that the world is
moving away from fossil fuels which i
think until the last month a lot of
people believed even though the data
didn't show it i think now people are
seeing oh the sun and the wind aren't
working too well in europe and it's not
going to work much better in the winter
so people are scrambling for fossil
fuels and you're hearing stories about
fossil fuels revenge and fossil fuels
are making a comeback but there was
really this view that you didn't that
they were really on the way out and that
was never true but china is kind of the
most obvious example because if you look
at the amount of tax electricity that a
place like texas uses china has three
times that amount
just in the pipeline for the amount of
coal they're going to add so never mind
the coal they're using which is many
multiples they're adding three times
texas worth of electricity in terms of
coal going forward so that just really i
mean i have this book it's kind of
fossil future and that has two meanings
one is that we should have a fossil
future that's the right thing that's my
main focus but the other thing is we are
going to have a fossil future whatever
people say the real risk you mentioned
europe and north america is that we
unilaterally hurt ourselves
and
and that is going to be disastrous so
it's very possible the u.s i think it's
almost inevitable europe makes a bunch
of suicidal decisions because that's
kind of what they do
throughout history they follow their own
ideas and we usually trail them
so i think it's you know someone in the
world is going to totally wreck their
economy and their citizens by pursuing
this and obviously china's not going to
do it obviously russia is not going to
do it and obviously india's not going to
do it i don't mean to equate india with
china and russia because india's far
more moral place in terms of its
government but those three places just
show yeah we are headed toward a fossil
future and if you care about co2 the
only thing you can really do is advocate
liberating lower cost alternatives
particularly nuclear and so i'm a very
adverse avid advocate of decriminalizing
nuclear and because i think that's the
only thing that really has the potential
to out-compete fossil fuels and even if
it doesn't out-compete it in the near
term we still need a lot more energy in
the world but notice that the
anti-fossil fuel movement is basically
the same as the anti-nuclear movement
and again it's because it's not about
better cleaner energy it's just about
eliminating all of our impact and really
being opposed to all forms of energy and
not caring about the fact that most of
the world lacks energy and not caring
what happens if they cut off our fossil
fuel supply
okay that was going to be one of my
questions is what should people do
but you're saying
we're contributing we're probably one of
the side effects is co2 increased co2
emissions and nuclear has less of that
than fossil fuels
yeah i mean i think i think in general
if you have the perspective of so people
look at the world and they think oh the
biggest problem the world is over
impacting climate and i would say no the
biggest problem in the world in this
domain is that the world is totally
underpowered the world needs so much
more energy than it currently has and so
that if that's your moral perspective
then it's really okay how do we get as
much energy produced for as many people
as possible and that means liberating
everything so liberating fossil fuel use
i mean you have you have laws that
protect you against like genuine abuses
uh you know against real pollution you
know that like you want certain levels
and that'll depend on the country and
how wealthy it is but you want to
liberate as many things as you can you
want to liberate nuclear i don't find
solar wind to be all that promising even
in 20 years but there could be ways in
which they're promising you want to
liberate those but they should have to
compete fairly they shouldn't be paid
the same for unreliable electricity as
reliable electricity there's some
promise longer term and what's called
geothermal that's still very small
uh hydro you should use where you can
although there are issues with
displacing people so it's a little bit
tricky there but in general the world is
underpowered politically we need to
liberate energy a lot more and then in
terms of ad in terms of individually i
think so it's supporting those policies
and also just
figuring out how to advocate them and my
main idea of how to advocate them
is share resources that do two things
and the number one thing is resources
that reframe the conversation i've been
arguing over and over i think it's
really about a different philosophy
thinking about this so share resources
that think about this issue in a more
pro-human way i think that some of the
people i've mentioned like bjorn lombor
also i think i don't know if you know
shellenberger i think he was on your
dad's podcast maybe michael schoenberger
like i think they're a growing group of
what i would call energy humanists and i
think what we have in common we have you
know a lot of small disagreements among
us but we have in common is we're all
looking at energy and climate in a big
picture pro-human way we're not just
saying oh it's bad for us to impact
climate so let's stop we say how big is
that impact how positive and negative
and how does it compare to the benefit
so i'd say look for resources that that
frame the issue in pro-human terms and
that are very accurate on the fact and
so my own contribution to this that's
free is just that website
energytalkingpoints.com
and the goal there is to give anyone the
resources to learn about any issue they
want with really good references and
then if you agree with it then you can
spread that message in i think very
effective ways
okay
that's interesting i haven't heard some
of these
points before
so this is fun um
i mean i started out people often think
like oh the fossil fuel industry must
have recruited you like i mean i came
from a liberal place
i didn't even know anyone in the fossil
fuel industry when i came up with my
ideas but but all of these ideas you
know some of which came from me some of
which came from other people like
it was a big deal to me like when i
realized that we were safer forever than
climate that really blew my mind because
i thought for sure
like cli we must be more endangered even
if fossil fuels are good in other ways
like surely you know more people are
dying from climate so when i learned oh
no it's at a record low
it really shook me in terms of oh
there's something really wrong with the
way i've been thinking about this issue
and the main thing was i didn't think
about how energy makes our environment
better i just thought oh energy can only
make our environment worse and then it
could offset that in other ways but no
no energy actually makes our environment
way better and we don't without energy
we don't have a livable environment
including we have a very dirty and
dangerous environment
so has anything gotten worse than in
terms of climate like have storms gotten
worse i know that there was a record
highs in alberta this year
it depends on what you mean by worse
because there's like ultimately
how climate as an interaction between
the the livability of climate is
interaction between what's happening in
the global climate system and the local
weather
and then us so you take something like a
storm like a storm that could have
destroyed a home 200 years ago can now
be a romantic setting for an evening
because of our level of mastery so i
think if you look at the livability of
climate no nothing has gone down because
our mastery ability is so great if you
look at things like oh is there anything
that's more negative kind of absent
mastery which is sort of hard to think
about
uh it's hard to say but if you just take
like there are certain i mean i would
say with warming you know there's pretty
clearly been about it i would say pretty
clearly at least been about a degree
celsius of warming in the last 150 years
or so
so you could look at okay where is that
more desirable and where is that less
desirable so there are things like that
there are questions of okay are there
places where there's more heat waves and
there are some of those uh so i don't
know if anyone could say anything is
globally more negative i think in
certain places yes
but i just want to say my argument is
true even if there are things like that
so even if we could be sure that storms
are 10 more dangerous
it really wouldn't be a problem at all
unless there was a trajectory that was
okay it's going to be 10 that is going
to be 25 right that kind of out of
control
and that's that's that this is another
philosophical issue i think people tend
to view climate and more broadly nature
as what i call a delicate nurturer so
this thing that's stable and sufficient
and safe unless we impact it and then
when we impact it it punishes us and
it's very much a hell narrative like if
we go against the god of nature like
it's we're gonna be thrown into this
hell and global warming is really a hell
kind of narrative like if you look at
how this actually works so we i
mentioned the planet has been 25 degrees
fahrenheit warmer it's also had at least
10 times the co2 levels as today and
those don't correlate perfectly at all
so we know we're not an unprecedented
territory with this planet we've had way
higher co2 levels way higher
temperatures all kinds of life thrive to
tend to thrive more when there's more
co2 because it leads to more plant
growth which is the basis of uh of
everything ultimately and so there's
just it's just really impossible that we
could make the planet unlivable what we
could do hypothetically is we could have
a rate of change that was negatively
disruptive so we could change from a
like cooler planet relatively speaking
because we're still a really cold planet
today relative history to a warmer
planet and because we've made a bunch of
investments then it could be
inconvenient based on the sea level
rises and just that you know temperature
changes and stuff
but it's being really slow so far like a
degree in 150 years it's not even
anywhere near the realm of it and people
talk about oh one you know you know
these numbers 1.5 degrees 2 degrees
they're talking about that's scary but
that means since the 1800s so 1.5
degrees really means 0.5 degrees and 2 2
degrees means 1 degree from now and
people are acting like that's terrifying
that's just a total denial of human
mastery and that that's a moral
perspective is just saying it was wrong
of us to change the temperature and i
just don't believe that i don't believe
that it's wrong for us to change the
earth i think we should do it
intelligently and so if there was a if
if we're doing it in a way that's
overall negative then we should change
but this this view that oh it's just
immoral to do and we should stop in a
world where again three billion people
use less electricity per person than a
refrigerator
like
i just i think it's totally morally
warped
yeah and anybody who thinks nature is
your friend hasn't seen horse flies in
canada have you ever seen a horse fly
uh i don't know they shouldn't exist
they're huge they're like this big they
look like house flies they take chunks
out of you anyway
yeah that's that's a good oh it's funny
like my my i'm very fortunate i have a
girlfriend who's very kind of pro-human
and not nature-worshiping in her
orientation and she's always saying like
oh that shouldn't exist
and that's kind of a good now you got to
be careful with certain bugs because
they are you know they are important in
different ways but it's like it's such a
rare attitude to just not worship nature
and it's not even nature it's like
conservative nature it's just nature
that we happen to inherit people are
just like they're just obsessed with the
way the earth was when i came into it
that's somehow perfect and then
theoretically the idea is oh the perfect
earth would be the earth that existed
had human beings never existed and i
just think it's a totally anti-human
view we're we are part of nature and i
think we're the best part of nature and
i think if martians saw us they think oh
those guys build the best nests and yeah
the dinosaurs change the earth and we
change the earth and we just want to do
so intelligently and i think overall
we've done so intelligently in some ways
not but and i'm open to discussing the
ways in which we haven't which we can do
better but if people say when they say
we've destroyed the earth like that is a
crazy perspective from a human
perspective because the earth has never
been a more livable place and you want
to talk about living in nature like 8
billion people living in nature that's 8
billion people dying in nature like the
population we have even if you want to
return to the old earth like it cannot
without machines you cannot support 8
billion people or even 3 billion people
so you need machines and that means you
need low-cost reliable energy for the
machines and in practice that means you
need a lot of fossil fuels and i think
we still need more of them
okay alex epstein that was awesome
if you want to direct people to anywhere
or if they want to go anywhere to find
you i think you've mentioned it but do
you have social media where's that what
websites
yeah so they can they can check out the
website um energytalkingpoints.com
and then the social media i'm by far the
most active on is twitter and it's just
my name at alex epstein and uh yeah i
post a lot of stuff there so yeah
between those two resources you should
be able to find anything you need and if
you go to the energytalkingpoints.com
website and you like my stuff there's
just a newsletter that you can sign up
for there so that's plenty okay thank
you very much for coming on all right
thank you this episode is also brought
to you by paleo valley 100 grass-fed
beef sticks paleo valley is unlike
anything else on the market they're
committed to making high-quality
clean products free of problematic
ingredients and farming practices that
harm the environment free
of those farming practices that harm the
environment their products come from
small family-owned farms right here in
the usa that use rotational grazing if
you want to look that up and their cows
are never fed grains or harmful
antibiotics
if you avoid meat for environmental
reasons you're going to love paleo
valley's grass-fed and finished beef
sticks
now you've probably heard of some of the
tricks companies use for product
taglines for instance did you know that
companies can claim their beef is
grass-fed as long as it was fed grass at
some point in its life
i find that hilarious or that meat can
be marked american made even if only
packaged in america
paleo valley is the real deal i
personally don't eat these because of
the lamb diet i have sensitivity to
spices
but i'm advertising them because there
are no preservatives no fillers just 100
american 100 grass-fed and finished beef
from domestic regenerative farms and
organic spices super clean ingredients
if you need a snack or trying to lose
weight
i can't eat them because i don't eat
spices but seriously stick with meat and
spices it's great you can help your body
and the environment by trying paleo
valley's high quality protein today just
head over i got a code for you guys mp
at paleo valley dot com for 15 off your
first order that's paleo valley dot com
with code mp for 15 off your first order
enjoy the rest of the episode
dr andrew destler welcome to my podcast
thank you
uh before we get started and i ask you a
bunch of questions can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
so i'm a professor of atmospheric
sciences at texas a m university and uh
for the last 20 years or so i've been
working on climate science so the
physics of climate as well as
climate policy
and um i've been getting into other
things like climate impacts recently so
in particular how climate change affects
infrastructure
like energy grids
okay and you've written a couple of
books uh yes i've written books on uh
two textbooks on
uh climate change and climate policy as
well as a book uh called introduction to
modern climate change which is just sort
of a primer of the whole climate problem
okay okay great so
this is an opposing views episode so i'm
going to have you on and then i'm going
to have somebody on who has an entirely
different view than you
uh and i'm going to ask you guys similar
questions
so i'll just start off
but that's the background this should be
a good episode
uh
first off
there's some question in some areas
about whether or not climate change is
one real and two caused by humans so
what are your views on that is it real
what is it caused by
yeah so climate change is is definitely
occurring and in fact i think there's
very little argument over that at this
point um even the the most ardent
opponents acknowledge the climate is
changing i mean all you have to do is
look out your window and as far as what
causes it there's immense consensus
99.99
agreement in the scientific community
based on me going to meetings and
talking to scientists that it's caused
by
uh human activities mainly the emission
of carbon dioxide and you know the
evidence is so strong that
if you were on a jury you would have no
qualms about convicting carbon dioxide
of of changing the climate
okay and the only way that carbon
dioxide is changing the climate is from
humans or there are other ways it could
be changing like are there other ways
that could be contributing to it that
aren't human
so carbon dioxide since pre-industrial
you know 1750 before humans started
burning fossil fuels has gone up
in the atmosphere about 40 and that is
entirely due to human activity there are
no natural sources that could have
increased carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
and there's multiple lines of evidence
again there's essentially no debate
about
what's driving
uh the increase in carbon dioxide which
is driving the increa the changes in
climate so
no there really are no competing
hypotheses now that's not to say
in a planet of seven billion people you
can't find someone who will claim
oh it's volcanoes or it's unicorns or
it's it's something but there's no
evidence for that and again if you go to
a meeting of people who are experts on
this people who've devoted their lives
to studying it uh you know they'll say
of course it's humans um you know we're
dumping billions of tons into the
atmosphere
every year and the amount of co2 in the
aperture is going up by billions of tons
i mean
if it's not humans where is all of the
emissions that we're emitting going
that seems fair
what are your thoughts on how to solve
this problem
so from a physics standpoint solving the
problem is simple we just need to stop
dumping carbon into the atmosphere now
from a policy standpoint it's a little
bit more difficult because
nobody dumps carbon in the atmosphere
for the sake of dumping carbon in the
atmosphere we do it as a it's a
byproduct of energy and we need we need
power i mean you know we need power
uh to survive nobody wants to live in a
world without power so the real
challenge is how do we
generate all the power we need without
dumping carbon into the atmosphere and
luckily the good news is we know how to
do it and in fact the cheapest energy
sources today are carbon free wind and
solar are now the cheapest energy
so
we can solve the problem uh from a
physics standpoint and from an energy
standpoint it's really a political
problem because the people who make a
lot of money
um
burning carbon and dumping carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere they do not
want to stop doing it and they really
don't care what the consequences are
because their bank account is flush with
cash
and those people have enormous power in
our political system and so regardless
of the consequences they want to keep
burning it so really that's the issue
the issue is how do we uh could
how do we politically
transition to a world where we're not
burning fossil fuels
aren't the green energy sources
more expensive for the consumer
actually they're they're much much
cheaper for the consumer if you look at
just the cost at the plug
wind and solar are now the cheapest
energy sources if you look at the texas
grid
and you look at what people say they're
going to be hooking up to the grid
nobody's hooking up natural gas nobody's
hooking up coal nobody's hooking up
nuclear everyone's hooking up wind and
solar because those are the cheap energy
sources and that doesn't even include
all of the enormous costs of fossil
fuels fossil fuels are incredibly
expensive let me let me explain this
this is something that everybody has to
understand when you buy a gallon of gas
when you buy a kilowatt hour of
electricity
you are not paying the full cost okay
you're not paying for the millions of
people who are killed every year from
air pollution from fossil fuels that's a
big drag on our economy you're not
paying for the climate change impacts
uh you know hurricane harvey
all the hurricane
hurricanes that hit
sea level rise extreme heat events in
the pacific northwest forest fires in
california all of those things are made
worse by climate change you don't pay
for that when you buy a gallon of gas in
addition there are these vicious price
swings with fossil fuels in fact europe
right now
is going through a period of extremely
high costs of natural gas
these vicious price swings are
economically destabilizing in fact if
you look at the us economy over the last
few decades the price swings have often
caused recessions those don't exist with
wind and solar so um
oh and finally
we have enormous subsidies for
fossil fuels you know one subsidy for
example is all the money we spend on
national defense i mean we have
engaged in two wars
over the last 20 years in the u.s
um in order to protect the price of oil
basically we invaded iraq twice and that
cost trillions of dollars and if you
incorporate all of the costs fossil
fuels are incredibly expensive
i mean there is no reason for us to
continue
a fossil fuel economy
except for the power that fossil fuel
uh producers have in our political
system if they didn't have the this
power we would be switching to
renewables at a very rapid rate because
they are the cheapest energy the best
for the economy they're the best for
most people not for the very small
people that own fossil fuel
infrastructure but for everybody else
renewable energy is the cheapest is the
best it will fill your wall with money
compared to fossil fuels
okay how do you feel about nuclear power
i think i've heard i've talked i've had
other people on the podcast talk about
climate a couple of times i think and
i've heard
positive things about nuclear power so
yeah i mean so my my feeling about all
of the various energy sources is that
they should fight it out on a level
playing field uh you know fossil fuels
should be fully priced
all of the all of the things in there
they should be priced if you did that
fossil fuels would disappear because
they're so expensive i feel nuclear is
the same way
nuclear right now is probably the only
energy source that's gotten more expense
over the last 10 years everything else
has gotten cheaper but nuclear has
gotten more expensive now it's possible
that someone will come with a design
that's very cheap
in which case i would be okay with that
but as of right now nuclear is just not
competitive um and uh until it is
competitive with wind and solar which
are very cheap and getting cheaper uh
you know i don't see any reason to build
it there's no there's no
fundamental reason to build nuclear over
over any other source of power
until it gets cheaper
okay and then
with solar
not solar wind turbines so last i think
it was last year in when texas froze
didn't some of the wind turbines freeze
so during the texas blackout in february
um
many energy sources underproduced so
there were some wind turbines
that did seem to not produce and that
was because you know they weren't
designed
to work in those temperatures you can
build wind turbines that work in very
cold temperatures but those wind
turbines simply weren't designed with
the equipment needed to operate in low
temperatures the important thing to
understand about
about the blackout though is that it was
mainly a failure of fossil fuel
infrastructure it was not a failure of
wind turbines it was
almost 100 percent due to natural gas
okay and how did that i'm i'm not very
familiar with what happened to tell you
the truth so how did how did natural gas
fail then
they just run out yeah so it was a long
story and but but basically the problem
with the natural gas infrastructure in
texas is that it's not designed to run
at very cold temperatures so a lot of
the gas that comes out of the ground in
texas has water in it
and at very cold temperatures
gas comes out with water the water
freezes
and it then plugs up the well so you
don't get any gas coming out
and in addition a lot of the natural gas
infrastructure is driven by electricity
so then when the natural gas went out
that caused a lot of power to be lost
once the power was lost
the natural gas that was still producing
stopped being produced because the
compressors and valves all that stuff
runs on electricity the electricity went
down a lot of them were not designated
as critical infrastructure that the
electricity companies would keep the
power flowing to under any circumstances
so they got cut off so is a real
disaster
and you know this is an issue with how
the free market energy system in texas
is designed there's no incentive for
energy manufacturers to spend money to
weatherize
their their
natural gas infrastructure because
when the power goes out they don't pay
for it you know it's society that pays
150 200 billion dollars it's not the
natural gas producers you know they lose
a little bit of revenue
um
you know it's not a big deal for them
why would they spend a lot of money
winterizing and making sure their their
infrastructure's robust it doesn't it's
a it's a good business decision for them
but it's terrible for society
okay okay that makes sense so
you talked a little bit about how to
solve the problem which is to release
less co2
what happens and you're saying that
renewable energy could be cheaper but at
the moment i know so i know that you can
get
heat shortages for people who can't
afford heat properly this is another
argument that's commonly brought up that
if you crank up the price of natural gas
then you start pricing people out of the
market and then that affects older
people or people who don't have as much
money and you end up with people who
don't have enough heat in the winter
time so how do you start addressing like
is is raising the the price of natural
gas an appropriate response to trying to
reduce the amount of natural gas that
that's i guess
used
right so one of the policy responses is
indeed something like a carbon tax which
would raise the price of of energy in
proportion to how much carbon dioxide it
emits so it wouldn't raise the price of
solar and wind wouldn't raise the price
of nuclear wouldn't raise the price of
hydro but it would raise the price of
gas a bit it would raise the price of
coal power a lot
now
one of the arguments you always do here
is oh this is going to bankrupt
middle class families and it's going to
throw people out of work so there are a
couple responses to that um number one
people are incredibly clever and once
there's a price on something
the solution to that ways to get around
that will be very rapidly uh innovative
so people often talk about innovation
as the key to this and so how do you get
innovation well you put a price on
something once there's a price on carbon
there will be a lot of innovation now
there nevertheless might be a period a
short period when you're waiting for
innovation to be
to occur and for
new energy sources to be deployed where
prices do go up but you have to realize
it's a carbon tax
the the increase in price is all going
to the government in the form of money
now they've got to do something with
that and so they can use that for
example to give money back to low-income
people so to to help them pay their
bills you don't want a regressive tax
and so people spend a lot of time
thinking about what's the right way to
recycle the money you get from a carbon
tax you can use it to reduce the debt
you could use it to reduce taxes on
other things you can use it to
supplement r d you could use it to
reimburse people with low income to help
them pay for the tax because you're
right you don't want people to go
without power
so potentially when a carbon tax bill is
introduced it would maybe be smarter if
they said okay we're going to tax people
but the money that we're getting from
that is going to go towards offsetting
some of the problems that creating
attacks would cause that might be a
better way to go about doing it yeah
absolutely in fact there's a lot of
groups out there that advocate exactly
that there's this group citizens climate
lobby where they advocate for something
called a cap and dividend i think is
what they call it where all of the money
raised just gets cut in a check and
distributed back to all the taxpayers so
um
you know the problem here is and this is
the key thing you've got to realize is
that the objections to it are not
because it's going to hurt low and
middle class people you know the people
who object to this it's not because we
can't do it it's because these people
are trying to protect the fossil fuel
industry so coming up with better
policies
doesn't solve the fundamental objection
these people have they'll never say it
but this is their fundamental objection
they will do everything to keep us
burning fossil fuels because that's how
people who produce fossil fuels make
money and they don't want to not make
money uh there's a very the very small
number of people who are tremendously
benefiting from our current system so
all these objections people bring up oh
you know it's it's
it's gonna be it's gonna be bad for poor
people and you say well here's a policy
workaround it never moves them because
that's not actually their objection they
don't care about the poor people they
care about fossil fuel producers and so
you know you've got to understand that's
the objection it is not all all of these
other problems are solvable the thing
you can't solve is for hustle fuel
producers they are going to get hurt
okay um and you know the the workers we
they can be retrained they'll be enor
there'll be new
jobs for them in the clean energy
industry but there's a small number of
people if you own a coal mine what are
you going to do if you own a oil well
services company actually oil services
companies could find jobs in renewable
energy
but there are a lot of there are a lot
of business there's there are some
businesses where the very rich owners
are not going to be able to recover from
this and those are the people who object
what percentage of co2 emissions are
actually
from americans like is it not other
countries that are contributing more to
this problem
yeah so you know i
i
i'm not sure i know the exact number but
it's about it's about a sixth of
emissions come from the us maybe it's
actually it's probably less than that
now
don't quote me on exact number but the
us is the um second largest emitter
behind china so china is a large
submitter china has four times as many
people though so per capita their
emissions per person their emissions are
lower than the u.s emissions
so the next question you're gonna ask is
you know why should the u.s do anything
if other countries aren't and you know
the us is a superpower you know we're a
world leader and other countries will
follow along with our lead and i know
people are skeptical that china's could
do anything but china has already agreed
to pique their emissions in 2030 and to
get emissions to zero in 2016. i would
just add that china is now also a world
leader in producing renewable energy
technology you know the us could have 20
years ago
been the leader in producing solar
panels producing wind turbines etc but
you know we essentially
we just ignored that opportunity and now
china is the world leader so they are
really going to be behind renewable
energy and they also have big air
pollution problems which they can solve
by stopping burning coal so the rest of
the world will go along with it once the
u.s and europe and all the other big
countries commit to it everyone else
will have to go along with it so i think
that in many ways it is the u.s that's
that's keeping world progress from
happening and once the u.s commits and
people believe it uh then i think you'll
see a lot of progress i mean you know i
i can't overstate kind of the damage
that trump did to the u.s credibility on
the issue and i do think a lot of other
countries think well you know biden's
saying the right things now but who
knows who's going to be elected in 2024
and maybe they're just going to reverse
the us position again and so people
don't look at us as reliable partners on
this problem and that really hurts the
politics
is there an issue with storing renewable
energy
okay so when you talk about how would
you actually build a grid
that is running on renewable energy
there are obviously some challenges and
one of them is the intermittency
of
solar and wind and so clearly
any renewable energy grid will mainly be
solar and wind but you can't rely 100 on
solar wind because of the intermittency
problems now there are several ways to
get around the intermittency so one way
is to build lots of transmission lines
because while the sun may not be shining
where you are or the wind blowing it's
shining uh the sun is shining the wind
is blowing
somewhere probably not too far away from
you and you can just transport the
energy uh by by power grids by the power
grid you can wheel energy around as they
say so that's one way to do it another
way to do it is to store the energy so
you build batteries for example and the
price of batteries is coming down
i think there needs to be some
technological development innovation in
the battery space and the way to do that
by the way is to put a price on carbon
if you have a carbon tax that will tell
people we need to spend more money doing
r d on batteries because if we make a
cheaper battery we are going to get rich
so so i do think there needs to be more
uh r d and batteries but batteries
clearly even now there are batteries
being built so people view them as
profitable
um
profitable
business areas um
there's also
you do need
some
firm dispatchable energy so something
that you can just flip the switch and
turn on all the time you need probably
10 or 20 percent of your energy needs to
be firm and dispatchable uh and that
could be nuclear it could be
hydroelectric it could be geothermal you
know maybe even for 10 of your power you
keep coal you are not coal you keep
natural gas with carbon capture
there are lots of
there are lots of uh
options for that last 10 or 20 percent
that's really hard to solve with wind
and solar because of their intermittency
and lastly there's what we call demand
response so you get people to agree
that if it in times when the energy is
short maybe you don't run your
dishwasher you don't run your
washing machine and you don't ask people
to do this you have smart appliances
which can detect uh the energy level and
maybe delay starting until the middle of
the night
you can also
do demand response with industrial
industrial
consumers and essentially all they do is
is your time shifting the demand instead
of using energy right now when there's
maybe a shortfall of energy because
you're not generating as much solar as
you thought you shift it to a time when
there's more energy available uh and so
the combination of all of these things
would allow us to build a renewable grid
that essentially satisfies uh our energy
24 hours a day seven days a week when
you flip a switch there's power there
and that's really what people care about
people really don't care about anything
else they just want power when they want
it at a price
that's reasonable and we can do that
yeah that sounds like a lot of
infrastructure to set up but you think
that starts with a carbon tax starts
with some money from somewhere right and
a need for it
or running out of some other type of
energy i suppose yeah i mean so i think
the the mistake you're making here is
that you're positing a world where we
don't spend money versus a world where
we do spend money
in all cases
we're going to be spending money the
question is what kind of world you want
to live in do you want to live in a
world where we're spending all of our
money building sea walls to protect
cities rebuilding cities after they get
destroyed by turbocharged hurricanes uh
rebuilding houses that burn in forest
fires in california building flood
infrastructure so we can do we can live
in that world a world where we're
spending all of our income trying to
stay alive or we can live in a world
where we spend the money building
transmission lines and solar energy and
wind turbines and then we don't live in
that world and that second world is a
world where we don't have savage price
swings from
oil and gas prices we don't have air
pollution killing tens of thousands of
americans every year millions of people
worldwide um you know we're not invading
iraq uh you know it's it's a that's in
my opinion speaking as a citizen here
that's a better world and i'd much
rather spend money
rebuilding our energy infrastructure
than spending money rebuilding cities
after they get hammered by climate
change
it's fair
what's the time frame for some of these
disasters or is that something we're
seeing already i mean you talked about
the war but i mean for things like sea
levels rising and having to build walls
or really dangerous hurricanes is that
happening now or is that something
that's happening in 10 years no climate
change is here and um you know
as i tell my students you know i expect
a lot of my students to live to 2100 uh
they're going to live through it and
they're going to be affected by the
decisions that we make in the next
decade or two and um you know
we're seeing heat waves we're seeing
extreme floods we're seeing uh
more damage from hurricanes and we're
seeing everything and the thing that's
important to understand is this is a
small preview of what's coming we've had
one degree celsius about two degrees
fahrenheit of warming
and we're already seeing the impacts now
imagine a world with three degrees
celsius about six degrees fahrenheit of
warming it's going to be far worse than
three times as bad because
the impacts are non-linear which means
every degree gives you a lot more damage
the previous degree so
you know this is a small preview of
what's coming and it's going to be much
much worse and
you know we control to a large extent
what kind of world we want to live in
but we have to make the decisions
relatively soon and you know
it's not always looking good
yeah i think some i think some of the
skepticism okay so say me growing up
um i was i remember hearing oh we're
running out of gas
in the 90s i think and then i can
remember my dad being like yeah well
they said that in the 70s and then it
didn't happen then you know just
skeptical and then
i don't have any understanding of say
there's a hurricane here i haven't been
hit by a hurricane so i haven't seen
that damage but are those actually
significantly worse than they were a
hundred years ago
um well i mean it depends so it depends
on exactly what um
what you're talking about so let me give
you a few examples so the pacific
northwest heat wave that just occurred
you know those temperatures were off the
chart
terrible i mean in canada there was oh
yeah litten that got to 50 celsius uh
maybe not quite 50 but almost 50 celsius
over 120 fahrenheit and then the next
day it burned down um you know just the
the
heat waves
are off the chart i mean they're they're
worse than predicted by climate models
um
you know if you look at intense rainfall
events so we can see rainfall is getting
more intense exactly along the lines of
what was predicted by models when we
talk about hurricanes hurricanes are a
bit tricky because they're infrequent
but catastrophic events so getting
statistics on things like a number of
occurrences is really kind of hard and
so we don't really have a good feeling
for the numbers of storms
but we do have a sense that storms are
going to be rainier and they're going to
be more intense again we don't
necessarily have data that show that
because they're so they're just not well
measured in the historical record but we
have good strong physical theories and
physics works so if the physics tells
you something's going to happen it's
probably going to happen
the heat wave uh i had friends in
alberta when the heat wave hit and it
was like people died that was intense
that was strange yeah
yeah i know i mean people die and and
you know it's it's
it's uh
it's a tragedy um and he's been you know
the thing the thing to look at and the
thing to realize again this is one
degree celsius of warming is that we are
not prepared for the kinds of changes
that are coming you know our world
is designed
to live in a certain temperature range
because of all the infrastructure that
we build is designed for temperature
range and as the temperature departs
that range
the world that we've designed is no
longer appropriate for it so people
don't have air conditioning in these
places that are going to get really hot
and so your choice is uh you know
installing air conditioning is thousands
of dollars
or you suffer and you know if you're if
you're poor and your health is bad then
you die and so it's you know it's going
to be very tough and uh you know i
understand you personally may not have
been affected by it but i guarantee
uh one of these days you're going to
wake up and you're going to say wow this
is terrible and it's not going to be
it's it's
people are
people are affected by thresholds in the
climate system it's not the case that
things get a little bit worse every year
and over many years they get really bad
what it is is there's no effect no
effect no effect and all of a sudden
things get really bad very quickly
uh and so you you probably sit there you
think well i'm fine and you very well
might have been fine up till now but you
know next year or the year after that or
in 10 years i don't know exactly when
you're going to wake up and something
really bad will have happened you'll
think wow this has really affected me
and i never saw it coming
but i'm telling you it's coming
so say
we switched over to renewable energy
sources now how much of this is
reversible
well very little of it is reversible in
the sense that uh carbon dioxide stays
in the atmosphere essentially forever
on human times on the time skills we
care about it's effectively forever it's
really you know hundreds or thousands of
years uh and so once we've emitted
carbon the atmosphere it it stays around
uh but
uh but that means that we can stop
future warming we really can't reverse
the past warming and so that's important
to understand we are where we are
and we're not going to get back to
pre-industrial for a very long time but
we have a lot of control over what's
coming and if you look at the
predictions uh you know the difference
between a low emission scenario a world
where we take climate change seriously
and a world where we don't take climate
change seriously is several degrees
celsius
in 2100 so you know you very well might
live to 2100 and um you know those two
worlds are going to be very different
and one of them is going to be a much
better world than the other one that's
the low warming world and i guarantee
you do not want to be in the high
warming world i mean even though you
personally might be okay
it's not going to be a good world to
live in and we control that we just have
to make the right decisions
okay so me joking about just warming
canada up a little bit and then pausing
climate change there that's not actually
that funny
yeah no i mean a lot of a lot of these
places where people say oh i could use a
little climate change here you know
they're they're engineered they're
designed for the temperatures they
experience and if you if you move the
climate of san diego
to canada it would be a disaster i mean
all the ecosystems wouldn't be able to
handle it you know people's
the way people design the world all the
you know everything you build every
building every train track every bridge
is built with a range of climate in mind
and when the climate changes all of
those um
all of those
assumptions that go into the designs are
no longer appropriate
yeah and i guess we saw that in texas
last year
yeah that's exactly right i mean that's
why i tell people about the blackout i
don't i to be clear i don't think the
blackout the weather was caused by
climate change sometimes this gets cold
in texas and i think this that was the
case but what it shows you is you know
texas is fine at 28 degrees but when you
get you know 18 degrees and then 10
degrees texas is the whole system
collapses i mean so you don't have to
get very far outside the range of the
temperatures that you are designed for
before everything falls apart and it's
not the case that it falls apart
smoothly again as i said before
as the temperature goes down you're fine
you're fine you're fine and then at some
point your pipes freeze at that point
things get really bad very quickly it's
thresholds i mean that's the most
important thing that people have to
realize are thresholds in the climate
system when you pass them things go to
hell very very quickly and it's very
hard to tell when you're right on the
cusp of the threshold uh but a lot of
people are on the cusp of thresholds
there are a lot of people out there
thinking oh i'm fine
but you're not fine you're about to pass
a threshold and you are definitely not
going to be fine from that and
you know it's it's going to be a bad
ride if we don't do anything about it in
fact i mean it'll be bad for some people
even if we take action because we've let
things go so far but we can still
we can still head off the worst of the
impacts
and make a overall better world in many
other ways if we take uh if we
take action
are there other other countries that we
could be
following more right like are there
other countries that are ahead of say
the states and in climate change or a
response to it
oh sure there are there are lots of
countries you know the european union
has taken climate change far more
seriously than the us and you know it's
always it's always uh problematic to
compare countries because countries have
different issues you know the u.s we
have big cities that where everybody
owns a car whereas in europe the cities
are smaller they have better public
transportation but overall you know the
u.s is definitely
has been a laggard although
states and cities have been trying to do
well so if you look in the u.s the
federal government has basically done
nothing on climate change but states and
cities have been working and so they've
done a lot of i think positive things
but ultimately we need the federal
government to come in and really
uh we need an overarching national
policy on this uh this is a place where
the free market's not going to work it's
just not the free market will not work
on this and and so we need the
government to do that and there are
other countries that are far ahead of us
on this
okay actually well one question this
might be a silly question but haven't
there been periods of warming and
cooling throughout history and
can we be absolutely positive that this
is a period of warming
it's not just change right it's
specifically warming
yeah so the answer yeah so the answer to
your first half of the question is um is
absolutely climate has changed uh over
the earth's entire history so it is
completely reasonable to say
maybe the warming of the 20th century
and and you know the early 21st century
maybe that's also natural so that's a
completely reasonable initial question
now thing to realize is that um
scientists are not idiots so we've asked
ourselves that question also and we can
look at all of the things that have
caused the climate to change over
the geologic record things like the
orbit of the earth the movement of the
continents um you know we can look at
all we have a list we can look at all
the suspects
and the answer is none of them can
explain the warming but carbon dioxide
from fossil fuel combustion explains it
perfectly it perfectly 100
everything is explained by that
and so that's why
you know if you were on a jury
and um you know the prosecution said
look
there are no other there are no other
suspects we can eliminate every other
suspect and this
suspect carbon dioxide uh he dropped his
wallet at the crime scene we found his
fingerprints there he was videotaped
carrying
stuff out of the building when he robbed
it when he was arrested all the stolen
merchandise was in his trunk he was
bragging to his friends he did it i mean
the evidence supporting carbon dioxide
is just overwhelming it's like you know
if you're on a jury
and there wasn't all of the political
aspects and tribalism surrounding
climate change you'd say of course
climate of course carbon dioxide did it
i mean of course there's there's there's
really no dispute and um yes we've
looked at all the other suspects and no
none of them could have done it
okay wow
i think that wraps up for all the
questions i had
uh if people want to find you online or
find out more about this do you have any
place to direct people to
well if you're looking for information
on climate change you have a question is
it the sun
is it you know how do we know carbon
dioxide increases our due to humans i
would go to skepticalscience.com that's
my go-to resource when people ask me
questions they say where can i do this
it's really well designed
well vetted if you want to if you want
to go one layer deeper you can always
look at the reports uh scientific
assessments from the ipcc the
intergovernmental panel and climate
change the national academy of sciences
uh you know those have all of the
reference peer-reviewed literature the
problem of course is that there's a lot
of misinformation
online and so for so if you're really
trying to learn about climate change the
real challenge is uh figuring out you
know the correct information from the
incorrect information because there's a
lot of incorrect information much like
covid or anything else there's a lot of
misinformation out there and so really
that's the challenge and
you want to stick to um authoritative
sources not some dude with a blog or a
lot of twitter followers but people who
rely on the peer-reviewed literature
because that's how science works we rely
on the peer-reviewed literature and
that's the most um
the best representation of
of what the science says and the
scientific assessments reflect that
do you know okay i've one last question
do you know anything about hydrogen fuel
cells for storing renewable energy
so uh the short answer is no i don't
know a lot about hydrogen uh that said
you know i'm open to hydrogen i think
hydrogen needs to battle it out with
nuclear and solar and wind and
geothermal and if it turns out to be
cheaper than then
uh
then batteries for storing energy uh
then yeah
i'd love to see it but ultimately
at least so far hydrogen doesn't look
like it's going to be necessarily a
cheap source i mean hydrogen is really
hard to store and as anyone who's seen
the hindenburg knows that there are some
downsides to hydrogen
although that's actually probably not
fair i mean batteries can burn also so
but hydrogen is really hard to store
it's a very small molecule it leaks a
lot also you have to produce hydrogen
and you have to make sure you're
producing in a way that doesn't produce
carbon dioxide
uh so you've got to you've got to make
sure that you have a good clean source
of hydrogen you have to be able to store
it to transport it it's going to take a
lot of infrastructure and uh you know
it's got a if it competes on a cost
basis then right on
which renewable source energy do you
think is going to end up being the most
popular
well let's be wind and solar so wind and
solar are already the cheapest source of
energy we there the technology is you
know a century or several centuries old
we know how they work they've already
demonstrated the ability to produce a
lot of energy
uh so that they're going to be the the
linchpin of a renewable energy system
but you need all these other things to
handle the intermittency you need some
storage you need some transmission you
need 10 or 20 of firm dispatchable
renewable energy you need some demand
response you need other things also but
the most important energy will be wind
and solar
and this is also might be a silly
question but are there committees that
are trying to build the entire
infrastructure rather than just focusing
on hey we want more wind turbines or
more solar energy is is there somebody
over and i know that's supposed to be
the government's job but
are there other committees that are kind
of overseeing this saying hey this is
how we would store it we need 20 like
what you're saying we need 20
of something that's a little bit faster
to get like do they have these big plans
somewhere out there so there are plans
that people that think tanks and
universities have put together on how do
we get to zero emissions i mean there's
no single government entity that's
tasked with our entire energy system so
there are regulatory bodies that that
oversee the grid and their regulatory
bodies that oversee
fossil fuel production and oversee
nuclear energy but they're really not
integrated i mean i think that's
um something that the government needs
to do
uh but there that doesn't really exist
right now
okay i think that was all my questions
then dr destler thank you very much for
coming on is there anything else you
want to talk about
you know the only thing i would say and
i this may not come up or may come up is
that i think we should be very grateful
to fossil fuels
uh for getting us where we are um you
know we live a great life because of
fossil fuels and i'm eternally grateful
to them and so the question is not are
fossil fuel were fossil fuels good of
course they were the question is what
what future do we want to live in do we
want to live in a world where we
continue burning fossil fuels or a world
where we kind of say let's take the
training wheels off
and um
you know go with go with a better energy
source you know as i alluded to you know
training wheels you put on your bike at
first but at some point you take them
off because you grow past it i think
we've grown past fossil fuels
i like that ending okay well thank you
very much for coming on that was good
that was a great discussion i appreciate
it
[Music]
you